denise had us at dogs and those are
happy dogs yeah you know you see those
the kind of grin with the tongue hanging
out and the tail going down stop they're
having so much fun
yesterday it was 72 in balmy and then
today kind of went off a cliff but
nothing even with the gray windy weather
nothing compared to three years ago
right over your right shoulder you
remember this i do and i asked on social
too hey if you remember this date send
us your pictures and yeah we're getting
bombarded with all your pictures keep
sending to us this one from kim through
him who showed us all the snow we had on
this day back in 2019 then we move on to
aaron dignan who look at this the luxor
actually getting snow on it now that is
rare and this happened again
on this date three years ago diana sakai
sent us this one she said it took me
over an hour to get out of my office
parking lot look at this snow here i'm
guessing that's out in summerlin judy
sent us this picture from centennial
hills so we thank you so much for
sending us your pictures and interacting
with us on social media 66 degrees our
official high for the day today after 72
yesterday look at this just a few digits
above our average and our record on the
state 80 degrees back in 1977 now here's
the deal we're going to go from above
average to below average not only
tomorrow but for several days 59 right
now centennial hills these are your
current temperatures 57
62 for the lakes spring valley included
633 downtown 66 sunrise manor 65 for
green valley road ranch 61. like i said
tomorrow we won't even reach the 60s
throughout many of our neighborhoods
tomorrow certainly not on thursday and
friday 60 in prom 59 boulder city
laughlin 68 degrees yes you're going to
need the jacket tomorrow and beyond
meanwhile soundline radar composite you
can see here the dip here in the jet
stream we're getting those southwest
winds with this but what we're going to
see is another wave that will come in
from the northwest and as far as shower
chances go it is possible out there but
again as you see in our future cast the
most the bulk of that energy is really
going to be east of us we'll get some
showers and snow first in the mountains
that's tomorrow at noon time and then
look at all this energy off towards
grand canyon mohave county east county
probably going to get some showers at 7
p.m tomorrow chances here to remain
fairly light and very slight for
tomorrow but then we get to wednesday
better chances overnight could get it
very isolated if you're looking for
widespread rain it's just not going to
happen we could have some passing
showers that entrench that mixing with
that colder air could actually give us
some flurries maybe a rainstorm mix and
some isolated isolated areas if that
does happen we ask you to send us your
pictures all right we want to see it now
we get to wednesday night and then all
starts to go away wind forecast for
tomorrow we will have those winds
unfortunately back again you see these
colors fire up yeah we could get gusts
up to 40 again for tomorrow and then
breezy by the time we get to tuesday or
i should say wednesday and then thursday
those winds relax even more so overnight
41 degrees chilly winds dusty still 56
tomorrow windy and cooler shower chances
really be later in the day or later in
the evening as far as those gusts go
like we said those will be up to 40
miles per hour here is your eight day
forecast now like we said chances
through wednesday like we said and those
numbers drop in the low 50s so look at
that cooling things off next week looks
a whole lot better as we get right back
to the 60s to even 70s so just hang in
there it's going to look a lot better as
far as those conditions go meanwhile
check out this guys this is in italy
where mount aetna is once again blowing
its top a massive plume of ash steam
rose in the sky over sicily today look
at this video this is one of europe's
tallest and most active volcanoes the
nearby airport was shut down mount aetna
erupts several times a year but rarely
causes damage
interesting that